as we bring in Anthony Davis the Lakers
power forward six-time NBA all-star
joining us on behalf of Mobil 1 in their
sweepstakes which we'll talk about in a
moment good morning Anthony what was
your second best sport in high school
good morning uh second best for I only
played basketball but as a little kid
did you play baseball football I didn't
I wanted to play baseball and my dad
played baseball but we were playing
catch one day and he he threw the ball
he totally put the glove like right in
front of my face he threw the ball I
like Miss Marlowe it hit me in the mouth
I've also wondered that I think you were
six two six one is a sophomore and then
you grew to six ten as a senior but
because you had that time period where
you had to learn how to dribble the ball
if you're that small that short as a
guard how much like you look back on
that how important was that that you did
have that time where you had to learn
how to dribble a ball like a point guard
because today so having that skill set
when I was in high school you know
freshman sophomore year I'm kind of
carried over until my game you know
Connor in college and especially in NBA
so I think it was it was very important
you know throughout my throughout my
career who was the best player you
played against in high school at that
time not to go to a big high school and
we didn't play any like octane so and in
season heyyou circuit and i said i
played against everybody
you know Michael Gilchrist and Bradley
did all those guys and and season it was
probably jahlil okafor to be honest okay
alright
when did you know you could play like
when did you know you could be great I
think my senior year honestly obviously
I always had to the mind so I all one
goes today
MBA but I never knew that I can be like
really good until my senior year when I
had it both birth and then you know
everyone started talking about me and
then I end up becoming you know
number-one player the country and that's
when I knew I could be I could do
something special I know you went to
Michael Jordan's basketball camp
have you had a conversation with Michael
being a Bulls fan growing up I did it I
think the only time I talked to Michael
was at his his camp I think that was it
he came and spoke to the group and then
you know had a couple of conversations
here and there with some of the players
but that was the only time I had like a
real you know conversation with him wait
but but you didn't get a chance to ask
him a question
did he just say anybody got questions
did you raise your hand what would you
have asked Michael Jordan but I regret I
got I should ask a question but you know
you didn't want to be that first guy and
then it was late when it when the
cameras over so you know God really
wanted to you know go back to the rooms
and go to sleep and eat so you know you
asked the question of God looking at you
like what are you asking questions we
ready to go this way so I was kind of
nervous
when's the last time you swap jerseys
with somebody I just walked jerseys with
Drew holiday and the woman I think that
was the last time I've done it I did it
this year with Drew how many jerseys do
you have from other players
yeah our time our time give a man cave I
sort of like I kind of do but I kind of
don't I saw the next house I get out has
a that's like one thing I had an epsilon
collective Jerry's put
and the frame and hang them hang them up
everywhere so that's really what I
wanted man hey there's LeBron have a man
cave I'm not sure I'm not sure every
does well you went to the house for Taco
Tuesday so I don't know like LeBron
callate Jersey I don't think he gave
jersey from anyone else did you get one
from it I'm gonna get one I want to get
a couple of them and you know what the
trick is you always have somebody ask
for you you know get a ball below right
I'm going straight to the source
okay Anthony Davis Lakers power forward
six-time NBA all-star joining us on
behalf of Mobil 1
Mobil 1 sweepstakes how would you rank
your acting skills in the Mobil 1
commercial you know the commercials that
we've done or that I've done with mobile
one has been great so I think I think I
think I'll give it it you know eight
eight and a half
whoo okay I think it's very good and
then you're in space jams too aren't you
yeah how big a role do you have eight
eight big is a bigger role so who's got
the second biggest role behind LeBron I
can't remember I know it's him it's like
the characters that play with actors and
actresses at play his family but I know
he told me I was AIDS now I'm not sure
if he was saying it to make me more
excited to be in a film or what but I'm
gonna go with his word Anthony's joining
us on behalf of the launch of the
250,000 dollar mobile one sweepstakes so
if he has 5 or more points gets five or
more rebounds as five or more assists
five or more blocks or five or more
steals in a single game over a ten game
stretch one lucky fan will get 250,000
dollars this fans can register from now
December 18th until January 15 that
Mobile one dot us / on the line hundred
I do with that good and I have to I have
to get all tried to get five or more
points rebounds assists steals and and
blah oh oh yeah what makes it tougher
who's the best the best player you
played against this year this year oh
sure season you know I want to I want to
count any one year just because of the
fact it's early you know god I start to
find a rhythm now you know start guys
I'm definitely starting again the group
and we haven't played everyone yet so we
haven't played in though the Rockets who
know James is averaging 100 points a
game so we have a play everyone yet for
four and a fear do you think James
Harden's gonna score 70 or 80 in a game
they're sure really sure I mean the
things he ever doing the basketball
floor it's unreal we haven't seen anyone
like it you know get to the free-throw
line at ease and step back he's able to
pass so I think I think it's definitely
coming wouldn't you love to do that
where you just know that that LeBron is
going to say to you hey I want you to go
out and I want you to take 45 shots like
just a fun game how do you think you
could do a tea what's the most you ever
scored again the most ever scored 59 oh
and you could get Sam to do you get
simple mobile want to love that know
know that you don't know just scoring
you know you got to get everything else
there but wouldn't you rather have a
great block than a great dunk oh I think
it depends on like his late game you
know we need to stop there you know I'm
taking them I'm taking the block but it
was early in the game we trying to get
the crowd into it you know I think I
think that doctors out the door but me
personally just been
are you able to defensive-minded I think
they're blog it's better than that done
are you talking on someone then I'll
take that older blog but just a regular
downs over a blog article blog who have
you posterized like your favorite one hi
everyone I think I was my second year in
the league I think it was going David
don't like my first poster ever like I
thought and I and I walked I was so
young I had no facial hair I had no my
hair was real low any it was barely off
the ground what you know Greendale's
couldn't get off the ground either he
can't jump he jumps like I do that
doesn't really count as a poster you
didn't get LeBron did you oh no I never
got LeBron why never got me another gun
I had was against the next a couple
years ago with Ron Vega and when that
doesn't count either Ron Baker jumped he
plays like I do come on I'm talking
about dunking on you know like Dwight
Howard or somebody like that
how about are you playing Thursday night
against the Greek freak angles and I'll
give you a couple of mobile one plugs if
you if you don't if you poster eyes the
Greek freak Anthony good luck with
mobile one and it sounds like an
interesting sweepstakes here
fans can register from December 18th
until January 15th at mobile one us
slash on the line and good luck with
that and hopefully we'll see you on
Thursday night all right
that's Anthony Davis he's a native of
the south side of Chicago there for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]